Carl Weathers sadly passed away on February
1.
Few performers had the kind of range the actor
exhibited across dozens of film and television projects.
Upon the news of his death, social media was
filled with his collaborators and fans mourning
the beloved actor.
With roles in the Rocky movies and "Predator,"
Carl Weathers was probably seen as more of
an action or dramatic actor to much of the
general public.
However, he proved just how hilarious he could
be with a starring turn in 1996's "Happy Gilmore."
He plays Chubbs, a former golfer who coaches
Happy to utilize his golfing prowess to the
fullest extent, waving a fake hand around
all the while.
"Think of a place that you believe perfect.
Your own happy place!"
Sandler took to Instagram to express his sorrow
at Weathers' passing, reflecting on what a
great guy he was all around beyond simply
being a tremendous actor.
"A true great man.
Great dad.
Great actor.
Great athlete.
So much fun to be around always.
Smart as hell.
Loyal as hell.
Funny as hell.
Loved his sons more than anything.
What a guy!!"
Carl Weathers' most recent role prior to his
passing was Greef Karga on "The Mandalorian."
It's a role he occupied since the very first
episode, and he continued to appear throughout
its run as recently as Season 3.
Karga became one of Din Djarin's closest allies,
and Weathers even directed a couple of episodes
of the Star Wars series.
He's been a bright spot in the franchise,
and on Instagram, Pascal remembers his friend
with a quick statement that sums up the actor's
death:
"Words fail."
By the sound of it, Weathers had big plans
in mind for continuing Karga's journey.
In an interview with Hypebeast, Weathers detailed
what he foresaw as the future of the character:
"I can see him not only protecting Nevarro
but becoming the tip of the spear in guarding
the planet.
If there are any entities that want to come
in and take over, I don't think Greef Karga
is going to be a shy guy in stepping out front
and putting on his battle gear."
Ahmed Best faced a great deal of unfair criticism
after playing Jar Jar Binks in the Star Wars
prequels.
In 2023, Best returned to Star Wars, playing
Kelleran Beq in "The Foundling," an episode
of "The Mandalorian" that was directed by
Carl Weathers.
On Instagram, Best posted a beautiful statement
on Carl Weathers, including a picture of the
two of them smiling.
Best mentions looking up to Weathers ever
since he was a kid.
Beyond that, Best reflected on how Weathers
helped him return to Star Wars:
"He saw how nervous I was to be back in #starwars
and gave me the strength and confidence to
perform."
Legacy sequels are always a risky proposition,
but "Creed" defied the odds and launched a
whole new franchise from where the Rocky films
left off.
The film stars Michael B. Jordan as Adonis
Creed, son of Apollo Creed, whom Carl Weathers
played in several movies.
Weathers wasn't in any of the Creed movies,
but his presence could be felt.
It only makes sense that Jordan would honor
the man whose footsteps he walks in.
On his Instagram stories, Jordan posted a
picture of Weathers along with the statement:
"We lost a legend."
Weathers may not have appeared alongside Jordan
in the Creed films, but he loved what the
actor did with the character.
Shortly after the release of the first "Creed"
movie, Weathers posted on X, formerly known
as Twitter,
"@michaelb4jordan You did well for the CREED
name!
Congrats on [a] great job, my friend!
May your success continue."
It's safe to say Jon Favreau respected Carl
Weathers on another level, as they were both
actors who eventually made their way to director's
chairs.
Additionally, the two worked together on "The
Mandalorian."
Favreau's statement on Weathers' passing was
posted to StarWars.com, and it honors his
lengthy legacy.
Favreau wrote,
"I am heartbroken by this devastating loss.
He was a hero from my childhood who I was
lucky enough to meet and then had the amazing
good fortune to work with.
He had the energy and curiosity of a young
man paired with the wisdom that his rich life
and career afforded him.
My heart goes out to his family and countless
admirers."
"Dillon, you son of a b----!"
With that one statement in "Predator" between
Dutch and Dillon, as well as two manly hands
clasping, a meme was born.
And the interaction might as well have really
summed up the friendship between the two actors,
as Schwarzenegger reflected on X on losing
such an incredible performer.
Schwarzenegger wrote about all Weathers managed
to accomplish throughout an extraordinary career.
Additionally, he wrote how he helped make
"Predator" the influential film it became.
He wrote,
"We couldn't have made Predator without him.
And we certainly wouldn't have had such a
wonderful time making it."
It appears the feeling was mutual, as Weathers
told Red Carpet News TV in 2016,
"We had a lot of fun, too.
Lot of great guys on that movie."
Carl Weathers' comedic sensibilities in "Happy
Gilmore" shouldn't have been a surprise to
anyone who watched him host "Saturday Night
Live" on January 30, 1988.
Weathers starred in an array of sketches,
including an installment of "Master Thespian,"
a recurring character played by Jon Lovitz.
The show may have happened over 35 years ago,
but Lovitz still remembers what an astounding
performer Weathers was.
On X, Lovitz reflected on getting to work
with Weathers all those years ago while also
reflecting on how spectacular he was in "Rocky."
Weathers' comedic timing would be on full
display over the years, as he would play himself
on "Arrested Development" and voiced the Basketball
King on "Regular Show."
He truly could do it all.
Jones referred to Weathers as "Apollo Creed"
in a post to X while posting a picture of
his character, Dillon, in "Predator."
Another comedian, Dane Cook, offered a tribute
on X to Weathers, also pointing toward his
performance as Apollo Creed as one for the
ages.
Weathers may be gone, but his influence will
remain through an astonishingly excellent
body of work.
Many of his colleagues will continue to remember
him, and that holds true for numerous fans
who cherish Weathers' movies.